all right everybody hope you
good morning today and enjoyed your
lunch thanks for joining us today I'm
very happy to be moderating a GCP
partner panel where we have four
industry experts who are here to talk to
us a little bit about some of the
practical strategies they've had helping
customers move to the cloud a quick
round of introductions to my well to
your left is Mike pearl Mike is a
principal at PwC's US consulting
business Mike is PD boosie's technology
consulting leader for the technology
entertainment and media
telecommunications and hospitality
industries he also serves as PwC's
global cloud computing leader Mike has
been a leader in PwC's digital
transformation initiatives for several
years and was one of the principal
authors of the firm's digital
transformation framework and cloud
computing strategy
mike has over 22 years of management
technology consulting experience
delivering strategy design and
operations consulting as well as large
scale transformation and technology
services to clients across multiple
industries welcome Mike thank you
next we have John Crossway John is
Accenture CTO for the communications
median technology sector based in LA
John has spent 25 years working in the
industry and is for the past ten years
been responsible for Accenture largest
media clients including the Walt Disney
Company as the North American CTO for
CMT John leads technology consulting
which strives the center's broad
offerings spanning strategy consulting
technology operations and digital to
create end-to-end transformation on how
clients deliver technology in this
rapidly evolving market John is also
responsible for a century's digital
video practice which serves media cable
and telecom companies to launch evolve
and operate product in this
progressively disrupted market thanks
Sean next we have Mike Kavis Mike is
vice president and principal architect
at cloud technology partners Mike is the
distinguished author of architecting the
cloud and writes for book Forbes in the
virtualization practice Mike has held
various positions such as CTO chief
architect and VP of architecture his
current focus areas are IOT big data and
containers and finally last but not
least we have Buddha aya Gauri
Buddha is the chief solutions architect
and Google Alliance solutions head at
tech mahindra with over 20 years of
experience in a second leadership he
owns a large solutions portfolio across
a number of verticals
geudae has built several large delivery
teams and innovation centers and focuses
on in strategic adoption of cloud and
IOT please help me in joining our panel
so I'm like starting with you can you
just tell us a little bit more introduce
your firm and tell us a little bit about
kind of your areas of expertise and how
you've helped companies move to the
cloud sure so happy to be here
people probably recognize the the PwC
brand the largest professional services
firm in the world across accounting tax
and advisory business
and we a part of our advisory business
I'm a partner in our advisory business
we have consulting deals and our
forensics teams but within consulting we
focus quite a lot on large scale
business transformation and several
years ago I was asked to lead our our
cloud efforts and when we look at cloud
computing we look at it very
holistically across what it's doing for
an enterprise both within their IT
organization in their product
organization how organizations are
leveraging cloud to drive productivity
and transformation within particular
business units and I'm based here in the
Bay Area and so we we focus a lot on our
high tech and and now broader set of
clients on transforming how new services
and products that they can develop using
cloud technology to deliver to their
customers so a broad range of things and
you know I'm sure we'll get into some of
the discussions on specific details one
of the the interesting things here is
PwC we migrated away from our legacy
workplace productivity tools over to
Google for work
and now I'm leading a number of
initiatives in developing tools and
solutions on top of the Google cloud
platform that we're delivering to our
clients great thank you John you talk
for Accenture I glad to be here as well
most of you may have heard of Accenture
as well much like PwC we're a large
global management consulting firm we
have about 400,000 resources around the
world and we're really organized
resource wise around two key dimensions
one is capability all of our consultants
are based have a deep acumen in a
particular capability whether it's
strategy consulting operations digital
or technology and what we found in
addressing large enterprise cloud
transformation is that each of these
capabilities play a very key role in in
a successful transformation whether
you're defining the vision and the
roadmap standing up a particular cloud
implementation or designing an OP model
on how we organize resources on going
the other dimension is industry and
industry dictates you know how we where
we have individuals support which
clients and while most of the
considerations we look at in considering
a cloud journey are broadly applicable
across the market we do find that there
is some industry nuance then it can
affect any individual companies cloud
journey so for example in media we might
find that we start in the digital media
workflow space or with a large telco we
might start with our omni-channel
platform and the like all of our
customers are consuming cloud today
whether its individual SAS products
platforms like GCP where they're
building custom applications and the
like or buying storage and in compute
and you know we found that about 80% of
all companies are using infrastructure
as a service to some degree today
and the result of this pattern of
consumption is really these hybrid
environments and we found about 50% of
all companies have hybrid cloud
strategies and we think that is a
blueprint that is going to continue into
the future and it's guided how we've
invested in our cloud capability in
serving the market a couple of examples
I guess we have a we have a an
organization called cloud first where we
house about 21,000 skilled resources on
a broad set of leading cloud platforms
and products and we've spent years and
considerable R&D resources in developing
something called the extension cloud
platform which is an open multi vendor
platform that allows enables
organizations to effectively an
efficiency efficiently manage hybrid
environments get that out so any right I
hope that gives you a little bit of
insight and how we view the market like
I'm a cashier glad to be here you may
have not heard of us but we're cloud
technology partners based out of Boston
Massachusetts
our consultants live Everywhere's I'm
out of Tampa we have about 100 person
company we're we're kind of a born in
the cloud type company so a lot of our
people including myself come from the
enterprise some people run data centers
I myself have worked on distributed
systems and big data systems for years
and our goal is to accelerate the cloud
right accelerate whether you're moving
to the cloud or building into cloud
whatever you're doing we have a lot of
IP and and documented processes how to
get you there as fast as possible and we
iterate through things so that's that's
our story we do everything from cloud
migration cloud strategy to DevOps 2
containers technologies you name it we
kind of covered a broad spectrum
hi my name is Gregory and I come from
tech mahindra and we are a global si for
Google and we have very large practice
and various different areas of cloud we
have about 120,000 employees across the
globe you probably haven't heard much
about tech mahindra but we are
predominantly all over the globe a pack
a and Z and the Americas and we have we
are engaged actively and a lot of
telecom telecom being one of our largest
sector and then we are heavy into
automobile industry several different
verticals we come with a strong practice
and advisory services business
transformation projects and we have over
50 different services and product
frameworks so the key the key aspect of
our go-to-market strategy is to take
solutions it's basically solution based
approach where we have a number of
frameworks that likely including the
cloud migration strategy that we can
talk about and also it is different
service offerings and product offerings
across the various different industries
that I talked about predominantly in
analytics in telecommunications
telecommunications with analytics and
automobiles and with that yeah great
thanks why don't we do a quick sort of
market survey so can you talk a little
bit maybe we'll start with you today on
sort of the trends you're seeing what
are customers trying to do in the cloud
and wherever they see the most success
yeah so thanks for the question so we we
have noticed a lot of heavy trend
towards migrating the basically cloud is
here to stay
and there's a lot of stress on moving
their applications the most mostly the
on-premise applications what are the
forces may be moving over from like
another capex to an optics model the
focus is mostly on
getting onto the cloud and there's a lot
of confusion and fear and experience
that's lack of experience rather that's
kind of driving a lot of this like you
know the strategy towards moving over to
the cloud so we are noticing a lot of
like you know movement so to speak in
like you know moving some of the
reporting the dr application sort of the
cloud and then like you know so primary
difference are you seeing any different
mike yeah we're seeing a lot of movement
to the cloud both from native
development but one of the big drivers
is data center consolidation so a lot of
companies have 13 they need to get to 5
by X date and that's driving the the
kind of lift and shift mentally we don't
have time to kind of change the
architecture we just need to get there
consolidate you know get our expenses
down and then the next generation is how
do i modernize and really take advantage
of the high level feature to the cloud
yeah you know one thing I'd share I
guess is that you know each year
Accenture publishes a technology vision
we do this to identify what are the
trends that are we think are going to
affect our clients in a significant way
in a 18 to 36 month planning horizon and
one of the themes in this year's tech
vision was around the platform economy
and you know part of this exercise
includes a survey we surveyed about 3500
technology executives around the world
and it was interesting about 85% came
back with the statement that they
believe that their company is going to
move away from selling products today to
selling business outcomes through
managed services in the next three to
five years and we think this is a trend
that's really going to push traditional
companies to get into the platform
business as sort of their foundational
method of delivering products and
services and you can kind of start to
see some of that show up in the market
today you've got you've got companies
like General Motors who's implementing
you know my Chevrolet which is a
platform that integrates the buyers of
their electric vehicle the bolt right to
upload product or car vehicle
performance information trended
benchmarking against other drivers send
it to product development and the like
or or companies like Kaiser Permanente
was establishing a platform to collect
and manage electronic medical data but
also integrate all the broad ecosystem
players that help them collectively
serve their patients today or even
General Electric right whose certain to
pivot move away from their traditional
industrial manufacturing routes and
getting more into software and data so
we think this trend will continue and as
these epicenters in industry start to
mature they're gonna have to support
millions of end consumers thousands of
ecosystem partners operate in an
always-on environment which is going to
require them to work with you know
web-scale
large platform trusted platform
providers like Google and the light go
forward and I think Google happens to be
one that is well positioned to serve
this market in a lot of ways we believe
in their proven ability to look at their
core product and data and create new
interesting value-added services much
like the you know the vision API we saw
earlier in the keynote yeah I would just
add similarly at PwC each year we survey
over 1400 this year was over 1,400
CEOs globally and it's a pretty broad
split of sizes of organizations global
mix across all industries and for the
fourth year in a row the number one item
top of mind for CEOs was the impact
technology is going to have on their
business and both from the perspective
of how are they going to leverage new
technologies to create a competitive
advantage but also concern about smaller
organizations that have access to
platforms like the Google cloud platform
that can quickly create take IP and
create solutions and
really disrupt what what our clients are
trying to do in the market and so a lot
of the trend that we see from that and
actually interestingly enough this year
there was a bit of a pivot it's not just
about the technology but how is that
technology being leveraged to drive
innovation and innovation with respect
to product with respect to how they're
operating their business and this this
unique kind of interplay between how
technology gets leveraged for innovation
and how you're going to leverage and
identify talent to allow you to do that
and it's really all with respect to
moving faster in an ever and an ever
more dynamic marketplace and so you know
for instance we working with with Google
and on the Google cloud platform one of
the things that we thought was very
important was to you know the the number
one item that comes up is around
security is to really take that head-on
where we've developed our security
analytics platform leveraging the Google
cloud platform with this notion that
security of exclusion is is really a bit
of a myth you're you're always
compromised at some level and so the
goal is how quickly can you identify
what's happening within your environment
pinpoint where it is and remediate that
and so that's just an example similar to
what we're seeing with our in our survey
and at our clients but really starting
to look at how can you leverage this
technology to create something that is
differentiated for you in the market you
know I appreciate you Mike for bringing
up security you know I think one of the
themes that we just heard is sort of
this opportunity that's afforded by
technology in my cloud but also the
business transformation is happening and
the uncertainty and some of the fear
kind of that revolves around that so can
you talk a little bit too
some of the hurdles that you're seeing
companies facing and what what you guys
are doing to help them overcome those
hurdles yeah well when you when you
think about conservative organizations
our brand is relatively conservative so
you know we spent and I was up close and
personal when we made our decision
to move over to the Google cloud
platform and Google for work there was a
lot of a lot of questions understandably
because we're in a regulated environment
our audit business and a lot of
questions around security and how we
would manage that and working with
Google we were able to get through the
security questions but the biggest thing
that we're seeing is quite frankly
regulation compliance and regulation
understandably isn't keeping pace with
the the rate of change in technology and
so oftentimes the where there is amazing
technology that allows organizations to
connect better move faster in the market
there are regulations that were written
many years ago that didn't contemplate
the technologies that are that are there
today and so a lot of what we spend time
with our clients helping helping them
work with is is understanding what those
regulations are understanding how they
can apply those regulations in the
context of some of the hurdles that we
would see apply those regulations in
understanding how they can still get
benefit from the technology got it great
Johnny seeing anything different you
know the I mean you mentioned security
the only thing I'd add to that is that
definitely with all the with all the
cyber breaches recently right that's
obviously created a lot of anxiety one
pattern we have seen is that as as
clients get closer to the providers that
they've selected like a Google they
inevitably push through it and I think
it's more about just engaging with the
right vendors that you trust and at the
end of the day public cloud consumption
is raising is rising at 44 percent a
year right now and on-premise at nine
percent so the move to public cloud is
not
being it's not stopping because of
security but it's it's obviously always
the first thing I think the other common
barrier that we find is just a mental
barry of where to start right it can
seem very daunting there's a lot of you
know do we do a traditional lift and
shift do we do we do new on new you know
what is the what is the right the right
approach and honestly the the guidance
that we always give is is to really take
the time to put together a cloud
strategy in a vision and a road map and
all the due diligence that that implies
to allow you to move with confidence
because it really is a broad
transformation it's not about you know
procurement or finding a new hardware
you know infrastructure provider it's
it's a broad it's a broad transformation
that needs to be you know given that
level of diligence and then I think
lastly another hurdle we've seen is just
internal talent so as you might guess
most organizations don't have a breadth
of talent sitting there that understand
how to design cloud-based architectures
and in high velocity environments and
the like and so as you create your your
vision in your roadmap to roll out cloud
capability within your organization
having a talent plan that can keep pace
with that roadmap is is crucial great
yep the other thing is you know there's
a lot of mythology mythology mythology
about cloud security and stuff like that
so one of the first things we do we come
in and the first thing we do is a
workshop and we we kind of go through
all that and talk about myth versus
reality and you know we have a lot of
case studies of our own clients and
financial institutions and health
institutions that this is how they
overcame those hurdles and we have one
customer who's in the security space and
when heartbleed was going on that's well
how long does it take you to patch that
well it takes some months to provision a
server so I kind of drew this chart
that's okay over three months this is
how many heartbleed pipe things happen
so by the time you get rid of this one
there's four more this is another reason
to take advantage of the cloud right
infrastructures code
you can actually turn servers or vm's
around in minutes so it's it's kind of
level in the playing field there's a lot
of chatter and a lot of it comes from
companies are not benefiting from the
public hardware company private company
so it's a level of playing field showing
real use real use cases a real success
stories and just kind of yeah so from
our perspective when we go to a client I
mean typically nine out of ten cases
it's basically the security security is
job number one always and and we've
talked enough about that
however like no we need to I mean part
of the methodology and the framework
that we offer on a side note is we have
a complete a full fully matured
framework where we have we interview the
client and understand what they said
lock the security architecture is
currently what the security assets are
and move them over to the new platform
but it's not as simple as likely just
doing a lift and ship there so security
one side now we have that needs to be
basically addressed with performance
security performance and then we have
loss of control so there's a perception
among the the customer community about
losing all this infrastructure they've
invested already heavily into it
what are they going to do about it so
sometimes it's a balancing ad it's not a
straightforward answer it's a
one-size-fits-all does not work out here
they need to weigh their options on is
it like do they move now is it the right
time to move to the cloud and adopt the
best flower practices because it's a
it's it's an imperative I mean it's not
a question of choice as against do they
want to like no still hold on to their
like a no infrastructure and the
investments that they have so there's a
loss of control a storm now the other
aspect which is slightly tougher is what
we face is the business aspect so we
have changed management there's this
whole perception about loss of jobs I
mean what traditionally used to be the
hard jobs that we talked about like in
our moment back they could be
transformed right so how do we retrain
rescale the workers how does the
management look at that right so the
various different aspects to it now part
of that also goes along with the
reality of like the data residency
issues are they really ready for like
you know moving water that next stick
that makes a big leap to probably like
no segregate the data and moves part of
it order the cloud which is warning so
all these decisions we need to have a
holistic approach and that's what we
provide as a framework through a Haley
templated approach they're like you know
business application portfolio analysis
that we do and then we come up with a
very strong recommendations which
eventually is up with a client to adopt
I mean guided recommendation so in all
this like I think Mike was stating the
the speed is breakneck alright we're not
talking about a four year platform or
two years like in a roadmap it's
probably three months right and you have
to be very realistic because there's so
many options out there so many points
where you can like you know points of
failure so to speak so in all the like
through this entire journey
it becomes very imperative for our
customers and that's what they turn back
to us for is like you know they need to
have a trusted adviser by their side and
that's exactly what we provide so we had
just as a case in point is for the
audience also to know we have like you
know about just taking the figures
recently were the last quarter over
twenty six thousand twenty six thousand
ninety five successful application
migrations that we've done over to the
cloud and this is across 193 companies a
pack NZ and we're talking the entire
globe so we come with deep expertise
deep experience we pretty much have like
a no majority of the questions even
though the migration methodology and the
framework itself is evolving they're
very strong use cases and you can stop
by the booth if you want some more
details about it and I hope one point he
mentioned another barrier is that fear
of loss job and and what we really see
is you know when you go to the cloud you
automate a lot of this stuff you don't
lose the job you you let these people
work on higher value
and that and that's something they
needed because a lot of the stuff they
do they wish they had time to do these
higher-level tasks and that's one of the
beauty of the clouds it takes away that
mundane stuff that you have to work on
it frees you up to work on things that
really move the needle so it's not you
know no one's job given replace you
you're gonna work on more important
thing exactly its core was this context
right yeah so so kind of to the end of
the business transformation and the
organizational transformation to your
point that that cloud is enabling
there's going to be customers that are
kind of on different ends of the sort of
risk tolerance spectrum you know I think
John you were mentioning sort of that
choice between lift and shift or new on
new so what what types of things John
are are you advocating to some of your
more conservative customers who maybe
don't want to kind of jump in you know
headfirst from day one so we still
recommend that you do that they do think
through and have a deliberate strategy
and a road map even if that road map is
more conservative and aligns more with
their culture but you know a lot of
places they will start is you know new
on new is the easiest where it's
greenfield you they're likely consuming
cloud today in their in their
interactive businesses whether it's you
know mobile or online so and then and
then any sort of major inflection point
in which they're doing REO architecture
is an opportunity that we encourage them
to embrace I think the other area too is
sass which you know when we think of
cloud you think of custom development
and the like but you know moving from
you know instead of doing high-velocity
development in the public cloud with
sensitive data which is where everyone
gets a lot of anxiety you know adopting
SAS platforms as well as a way to ease
down that road and then the second is we
definitely encourage them to adopt a
platform when they when you look at if
you're going to move at a very you know
I'd say more deliberate or measured pace
it is it's hard to bring the
organization along if you just say hey
we're doing cloud right and so you know
here's some broad-based tools and
whatnot but if you come in with a
deliberate platform and set end and also
bundle it
or with with not just you know hey we're
doing cloud but you're bundling it with
a different way of delivery right and so
it probably is integrated with a number
of other initiatives that you have in
flight whether that's your agile
transformation or remember you're
implementing DevOps and and bundling
that together to where you're bringing
your organization along in this whole
notion of yes we do things differently
and we're producing different
architectures and we're moving at a
different pace and if that is
underpinned by a very deliberate
platform it it's much easier for an
organization to get their arms around so
Mike John John just talked about sort of
new on new being maybe the lowest risk
thing but also kind of having more of a
organization-wide strategy for cloud
adoption and roadmap are you guys what
are you guys doing that's maybe
different or in addition to that well I
I mean I would agree I think the you
know that it's the the question is not
if but when and the organization's
there's too much benefit in moving an
adopting cloud for organizations not to
move in that direction and so as John
pointed out you know we do the same with
our clients be thoughtful about what
you're ready for as well as what you're
not ready for and we also encourage
people to invest the time to really
understand what is the business value
that you're going to get out of it
because as you said you can't if you say
we're gonna do cloud for cloud sake you
know that that loses people they want to
understand if you can articulate the
speed at which at which you know teams
can collaborate differently across the
globe and compare a current state to
future state leveraging cloud platform
or articulate how transformation or
development of technology assets can go
from you know a procurement exercise
into months of development to weeks it
weeks and
you know outside a month those are the
types of things where people then start
to understand okay here's the value that
I'm going to get out of that and and
then then you're having a risk
discussion on very different terms
your your your agreed that you want to
move in the direction of business value
but you're thoughtful about the the
risks that you're willing to take and
moving in that direction great like one
of the there's a lot of areas to cover
around transformational organization
organizational change one area that gets
forgotten a lot about a lot of times its
developer led so it's get the first apps
and forget about the operation side how
do I run this how do I keep track the
cost and everything and in in the data
center whether your processes are good
or not
you know them and they've been in place
for twenty years now you're going to
this new platform you don't have
anything right so in the transformation
we make sure in sequence while you're
building architectures you're also
building out how do you how do you run
so that's a big piece of gets missed
well it's really easy to get stuff the
first few in the cloud then then you got
a thousand if you don't have how do I
run it it becomes worse than what you
had before right so you got to think
about the whole spectrum yeah so the
trend that we're seeing mostly so can't
you repeat the question one of the
hurdles are quite the question is for
the more conservative companies how are
you helping these companies kind of
adjust to that cloud adoption journey
you know we heard a little bit about
sort of the roadmap the planning the
process management and so on everything
that mostly mostly like I said earlier
like you know there is fear and the
experience that's lacking so they don't
know what they're up against
even though there is like you know
starting at the advisory board level at
the board level there is a mandate to
move to the cloud but they don't know
exactly how but it so our approach
generally we we advocate an approach
where we just want to move like no
bite-sized steps first before we make
the big leaps so definitely I mean
there's no one-size-fits-all but
typically
we would like and through this entire
portfolio analysis we do like in this
entire marketing of different
applications portfolio segmentation the
recommendations typically come across in
terms of what are the stuff that is that
is qualified for lift and shift right
and then lift and shift is one we are
collecting and re-engineering is another
one where there may be small tweaks here
and there that may be required however
that probably requires some more like
you know in-depth
recoding kind of stuff which is a little
slightly expensive and there are
applications which you don't want to
touch like it just it's better off on
compromising you probably may want to
think about sun setting those
applications as well so these are so
just a very interesting example we were
working on a with a media company and
also long ago this has been their
likeness into 1960s alright so there are
a whole bunch of code and COBOL driven
programs which is lying out there and
when we actually engaged with all
different the white the entire
cross-section of the IT community half
of them they do not even know what those
applications did alright so that's all
and this is something that I mean the
typical and suppose this was there since
you I joined I don't know exactly what
it does and there's a fear of uploading
that application because you don't know
what like and what wires they would be
unplugging by just moving it so I mean
there are some i opening exerciser which
which come as a part of this entire
exercise but the recommendation again
typically comes over like you know there
are non revenue facing applications non
business critical applications then you
want to kind of like you know put it on
the side just how a plan for it put in
the roadmap probably nine months later
but you want to just address the
low-hanging fruit right now and what are
those long hanging hanging fruits those
are like a typically reporting
applications d are kind of applications
disaster recovery which don't have a
high rate of RTO RPO kind of
requirements even if it is so the idea
is to have adopters and evangelists
internally from within the company who
can advocate for you right so just a few
successes here and there and slowly I
mean this is we actually seen this
translate into mega-project starting
with just moving a few reporting
applications you'd be surprised
now one more point that I'd like to add
here is the the kind of adoption the
kind of adoption that you'd see within
these enterprises is from it's it's
exponential you the the graph is not
Union like this it just goes like no
it's a straight curve first name when
you're talking about like no 5 10 20
applications reporting applications
after that they are just asking you like
the conversation changes they are
talking about moving the the p1
applications piece of applications order
management systems which are bravely
attached to the revenue and then the
security the security conversation
starts because that's where the entire
conversation starts right so the the
thing is while we're moving over to the
cloud how can we change our security
posture it's not about how can I protect
my existing data and move my existing
artifacts over to the cloud that is not
the composition it's mostly about how
can I change because they know like a
security person that they have hires
they probably not the best and they
probably are like you know two steps
behind the hackers who's like you know
trying to like you know break into their
applications but coming with cloud we
kind of make the point gradually it's
more your applications are safer sitting
in the cloud and that becomes easy
conversation so the whole thing starts
with going for the low-hanging fruits
and then making the conversation for
like you know a few steps first frog
before you run so it sounds like kind of
the goal here with these more
conservative enterprises is to sort of
generate internal support for cloud
adoption through kind of small low-risk
wins and try to use that to kind of grow
that engagement internally now we got a
chance to talk earlier to Spotify and to
Disney who have obviously been much more
aggressive more more progressive with
their plot adoption how does that change
your ability and what kind of dynamic
things are you guys doing with those
companies to have fewer constraints and
are willing to kind of jump into that
business transformation a little more
quickly like yeah well I you know the
the some of the things that we we've
highlighted here you know the the sky's
the limit if you will on what you can do
organizations that are moving very
aggressively towards towards the cloud
and leveraging it is again when when the
the value that they're able to generate
and the speed at which they're able to
again we with with our clients
we focus on this concept around high
velocity IT and it's based on cloud
infrastructure development platforms
that allow for the leveraging a DevOps
model that once you have the platform in
place and you highlighted from your some
of your research the these this platform
economy that is coming up companies that
start to move in that direction really
start to realize benefits maybe that
they didn't even think about you start
to put things into the cloud develop
services develop solutions and as you
continue to move in that direction you
learn more about what you can be doing
differently and so and that gets back to
that some of our research on our CEO
survey where this whole notion of
providing the proper tools to allow
people to innovate internally really
does change the game for organizations
that are ready to adopt it in a in an
aggressive way right so John you know we
Microsoft a little bit about like
developer velocity we also heard a lot
about things like the machine learning
and and and sort of data capabilities
what's sort of moving the needle for for
kind of your most sort of sophisticated
customers so the let's see I think you
know a lot of it is about and some of
these kind of build on a point that that
Mike made which is the promise of cloud
you know the companies go into it for a
number of reasons they feel like they
have to they're looking for efficiency
they want velocity and the like but the
reality is is that it's really one
element of a broader transformation in
changing the way they deliver technology
to support their business and often it's
driven by you know maybe a couple of
different factors one is that they need
to keep pace with the business which is
now operating in a market that demands a
quicker time to market more rapid and
intuitive innovation and at the same
time they've you know maybe you've come
to a maturity level on some traditional
models of offshoring and an outsourcing
you know like and now you need to get
that next level of productivity at a
technology delivery and so
looking at a number of different
concepts in high velocity or new ideas
Mike mentioned really come together
really need to be implemented in
aggregate to achieve the promise across
these and that includes you know
platforms and cloud but also DevOps and
instrumentation automation and and and
of course agile to get into iterative
development and those three together
particularly if you're moving fast the
only way to sustain that change and not
run into run into a bunch of barriers
after your initial sprint out of the
gate is to ensure that you've got the
right OP model and so you'reyou're just
constructing your organization to move
with these new tools and methods and in
for developers it's a completely
different way to operate right so for
engineers you got to you got to double
down on on the culture and on the talent
models such that you can keep that pace
but but that's what we found is that if
you you know if there is a lot of
excitement the company has a strategy
you know I think Mike's points around
making sure that vision ties to goals
that are measurable and everyone feels
accountable to and and then having this
comprehensive approach on how to get
there as would be my input so I wrote
this post on Forbes while back called
the four stages of cloud competence and
it matches with you know the old
psychology where competencies and at the
first phase it's like you don't know so
therefore you don't like so you don't
don't anything about cloud is it's bad
then the second stage is I kind of know
about it so I go into it and I'm
treating it like a theatre self right
and in the third stage is okay I've got
copies I've used the cloud and then you
start really taking advantage of some of
these high over level services and the
fourth level is you know I'm totally
competent and those are the companies
that see the cloud as a way to transform
the business and those are like the
Spotify those types of companies just
say I can use this in ways and change
the way we price things I change
business models I could offer services
before and we've seen all those types of
customers and there's a lot of different
examples but really a lot of how much
like there's a lot of companies coming
to the public cloud for the first time
but they've been building private clouds
for 2-3 years so they get cloud and a
lot of them come to a public cloud
because they said wow that's a lot of
hard work I don't want to do a lot of
that work anymore so you get that mix
with cops you but the more experienced
people having a cloud the more they move
up that stack they start using you know
these probably these services we saw
today but a lot of the early people are
like I'm afraid of lock-in so they just
treat it like a datacenter
and all they're really doing is they
have a virtual datacenter and they're
still doing all the same work they do
their data center we're just doing on a
cloud missing a big opportunity so who
did any examples you can share to Mike's
point of companies that have really kind
of gone to that Nevil next level of
abstraction you know really using the
higher order services and kind of try to
take full advantage of a bubble cloud
yeah absolutely so most of my discussion
points would go around core versus
context we already know about that right
so they're like you know points that
Joan raised about or he mentioned about
DevOps right so what we're talking about
the velocity is phenomenally increased
we all know that now I'll give you an
example again now we are just doing a
like you know proof of concept for
prospect it's a the the core business
model centers around heavy compute heavy
computer all right
now I don't want it like no yeah I
probably I it's fair to differentiate
also the other clouds which is what GCP
brought to the table is what used to
take like you know the the complex
algorithms that would be fed into with
petabytes of data that it would just dig
into it come back with the result would
take several like 45 minutes to an hour
for an average workload all right now we
just did a POC where we just got the
same amount of data and reach a quality
with richer analytics or with under 10
seconds so this is just one case point
so just think of the magnitude of
savings right so we're talking 45
minutes versus 10 seconds now that's not
the whole value proposition here now we
so certainly the moment we just
the good news goes across like wildfire
now they are not another like you know
the investors and and like you know the
the scene management are essentially
looking at how they can scale this
across a vast portfolio of their
application so we're talking of like a
significant enormous amounts of savings
for operational event efficiency now the
phd folks who are like you know
primarily working on the core
engineering and like in coming up with
new newer formula so to speak without
giving out too much of their business
model and what they're exactly doing
they are sitting side by side with the
folks who are actually calling it for
them and the results are instantaneous
so we see them needle moving heavily in
like in terms of operation efficiency
it's for real right so that's one
example and then we have so many
different like you know efficiency like
in our services coordinators being one
of them and then we have the vision API
it just basically opens up more
possibilities right and then certainly
like now we have a lot of visualization
aspect to this entire conversation that
comes up if you're talking logistics for
example we have a product core for
supply chain visibility platform which
basically brings a lot of all the entire
supply chain stakeholders onto a common
platform
it's basically we track inventory now on
top of that we are able to like you know
bring in a like you know a very rich
user look and feel like in a great high
level of user experience in various
different aspects so the conversation is
like you know has certainly risen in
terms of the capabilities that we can
bring how we can enable the business
using more enabling technologies so the
the possibilities all around right so a
lot of announcements that we heard in
the morning today in the morning they
directly address how each of these
services are ready address in the
business community so yeah it's it's in
multiple this it's hard to say there's
one single area but then if you had to
speak about it it's probably the the
time to market capability you have an
idea bring it to the marketers it's a
matter of probably slashed I won't say
days or months of hours but it's same
drastically its reduced so you have time
to market and then operational
efficiency are the two things that come
to my mind right now but they could
they are definitely more great thanks
now we're starting to run short on time
so I appreciate all your comments so far
if you can give the audience maybe just
one last parting thought on kind of if
they're starting their cloud migration
journey kind of what's the one piece of
advice you'd give starting with you Edie
sure yeah so one size fits all does not
work cloud migration has to happen all
right so we've read enough articles
enough material out there like you know
it's it's basically you want to focus on
your business versus you want to be
maintaining a whole bunch of metal boxes
and then kind of doing the
infrastructure kind of work right and
still be left behind now why the
transition will be pretty rapid I think
like if you just look fires back where
we were compared the conversation that
we're having right now is it's like you
know significantly different what I
think is along the way I mean there are
too many points of failure like I
mentioned because purely because of the
way your systems have been architected
or the kind of ecosystem that you
survive in or live in like a know
probably 25 or 30 years old application
still surviving out there it's time to
kind of do a overhaul so you need a
trusted adviser during this journey all
right and with us having done over
26,000 applications migrations they're
gonna put across all our client base we
come with a very rich methodology and a
framework to kind of handhold you to
success right well real quick cuz right
you start with a proven methodology
start small iterate learn hurry
great that's good quickly then I would
say operate with a plant create a plan
that's integrated with your broader
technology delivery transformation
don't forget OP model talent and culture
and the last is treated like the level
of transformation that it is and get
senior sponsorship that's going to be
visible throughout the journey to bring
everybody along yeah I would quickly say
you know touching on a point that I
raised earlier is this notion of it is a
transformation you're
want to bring your organization with you
so identify the business outcomes that
you're looking for and how clouds going
to help you achieve that and that will
drive a greater willingness for adoption
and you know I would agree with John on
the this notion of being thoughtful and
diligent about setting that plan once
you once you establish your business
goals be thoughtful about how you're
going to move towards achieving those
great well thank you all very much
please hold
you